[Music]
you are watching the press preview
a first look at what's on the front
pages as they arrive coming up
we'll see what's making the headlines
with the daily mirror economist susie
boniface and chief executive
of conservative home mark wallace so
let's see what's on some of those front
pages for you now
it's no surprise that matt hancock is on
almost all of the front pages the eye
describes him
as a hypocrite and says a poll suggests
most people think he should
resign the telegraph says public opinion
will likely determine the health
secretary's fate
the guardian says he's under relentless
pressure to stand down
but boris johnson is backing mr hancock
says the express
hopeless love rat backs hopeless love
rat
is the star's headline
while the mirror says cheat and liar dot
dot dot so pm
backs him how can he cling on
ask the daily mail
the financial times is the only paper
without matt hancock on the front page
its main story is spain rejecting calls
from germany
to force british tourists to quarantine
in every eu
country and we are joined tonight by
suzy boniface and
mark wallace to take us through those
newspapers welcome to you both um let's
start with the
mirror the headline there cheat and liar
dot dot dot so
pm backs him susie
yeah um boris johnson has expressed his
full confidence
in a man he was describing it's
completely hopeless not five minutes ago
um and he's in a difficult situation
because he
uh he has had extramarital affairs
himself he can't stack matt hancock for
that
even though he may have broken the
ministerial code uh he uh he can't sack
him for breaking the ministry of code
because pretty patel wasn't he can't
sack him for breach in covert rules
because dominic cummings did that
and he doesn't appear to have noticed
that he's actually broken the law as
well
by not having reasonably necessary work
meetings
with this lady so um bryce johnson's in
a bit of a sticky wicket also if he
does get rid of matt hancock he's then
gonna have a reshuffle
and he's got to move people around which
he doesn't want to do
uh he has to give in to media pressure
which he also doesn't want to do
but there's something here which lots of
people are forgetting all these
men in the newspapers talking about
whether matt hancock's going to go and
and whether boris johnson backs him or
not was almost irrelevant
because the real issue here is how much
of this mrs hancock can put up with
because you don't break a story on a
friday unless you've got a saturday on a
sunday
in the bag ready to go and there aren't
many wives
no matter what the state of your
marriage might be that are going to be
prepared to put up with three days of
revelations there's a video out tonight
on top of the still we had to endure
yesterday
um goodness knows what's going to be in
the sun on sunday but i'm sure there'll
be something
and matt hancock's going to be under
relentless pressure
never mind at work but from home i would
have thought because as long as he hangs
on to his job
journalists will keep digging they'll
keep digging into
links between his girlfriend and nhs
contracts they're going to keep digging
into who knew what when and when the
affairs started and began
and what the state of everybody's
relationships is and it's a question
that no one's going to be able to avoid
it they can't dodge it you can't outlive
it it's going to keep coming back for a
long time and
if i was mrs hancock i would be telling
my husband that he
had to step down pretty rapid to be
honest mark
what's your view is this a private
matter as some ministers
would have us believe today i heard from
grant shap
speaking earlier on sky news saying that
it was a a private matter
or or is this something that he really
should be held accountable for on on
very many levels as susie described
well look at the newspapers it couldn't
really be any less private could it i
mean the fact is that there's
you know i i think there is good reason
to say that
politicians are human beings they have
private lives but this is not
simply now a private matter the fact is
that there are three particular aspects
to it as i said the first
is the question of your personal
behavior in your in your
personal relationships with other people
that's something that some people
want will judge a politician on it's
something that other people will
will put aside but more you know mrs
hancock
as um as susie says is is the first and
foremost victim
in in all that but the two arguably
bigger issues and certainly the issues
of
public interest are firstly that this is
the
secretary of state who has been in
charge of setting these
extensive massive rules um really
difficult and hurtful and painful rules
for a lot of people
over the last 18 months whether people
have been specifically forbidden from
seeing
their partners you know the secretary of
state's been on tv
talking about whether sexual relations
are allowed with someone you don't live
with
um but also whether people are allowed
to say goodbye
um a loved one's deathbed or to visit
someone who is
vulnerable and alone in a nursing home
or living by themselves you know
that that resonates very deeply with
people if they see that there's
a different double standard and the
other aspect is this question of
the fact that there's a quick question
of the um
the other party here being a
non-executive director of the department
and that means brings in questions of
public scrutiny of how departments run
and of course of taxpayers money so
that's a long way of saying
what i said the outset this is not just
a private matter whether people protest
it is or not
it clearly isn't and suzy the next
question is can he survive the the male
saying how can he cling on
yep there are sort of some truisms in
journalism and politics
about how long a scandal how many how
many days of front pages can a political
career
uh maintain that you know survive and um
i think most people would agree that
this particular government doesn't
appear to be following the normal rules
on that sort of thing
uh ministers are surviving things that
they would have gone for
on under previous administrations
theresa may
would have would have dumped quite a few
of cabinet ministers by this point if
she'd had to endure it
but like i said mrs hancock's probably
going to be the person that actually
determines what happens next
uh whether she stands by her husband
whether she doesn't
whether she decides they want to try
again or fix their family
but that's going to determine whether or
not mr hancock wants to resign
whether or not he needs to resign and
what boris johnson wants isn't going to
be
at the top of mrs hancock's priorities i
wouldn't have thought for a moment and
as mark pointed out there
there are 400 000 people in care homes
who have not been able to see their
loved ones for a year and a half
on this man's instructions and partly
because of this man's failures at the
start of the pandemic there's 150 000
people who have died as a result of
covid
and many of them haven't seen their
loved ones even people who haven't died
as a result of it haven't had visits to
hospital and so on so
there are lots of very angry people in
britain tonight
there's those of us just talking and
loving the scandal but there's a lot of
really furious people out there quite
rightly um very very angry that the man
who kept them apart from their loved
ones at a terrible time
uh has been playing away from home um
mark we've heard from the the health
secretary um
saying that he actually does want to
continue in the job it doesn't seem as
though he's planning
to resign anytime soon we know that he's
got the full confidence
of boris johnson but do you think that
the prime minister's position
will change that he will have to bow to
pressure as you say
these are the headlines on friday night
and they're likely to be the headlines
throughout the weekend
well susie talked about one possible
scenario which is the the pressure that
might be applied hypothetically by mrs
hancock
in this particular situation but there
are a number of other different
um pressures that i suspect are going to
come to bear the first is of course that
his lover in this story could herself
choose choose to resign which one i
think the question um
it starts to be raised well if if one
party's gone one is the other
not uh there's the question that we see
a lot of which is aired in the deadly
telegraph's front page tonight
about exactly where the parliamentary
conservative party comes down on this
you know
the week of a politician uh takes
has a very particular shape the days you
spend in westminster are days you spend
talking to other politicians into the
media into your whips and the party
the days you spend at the weekend are
time you spend talking to your own
family
your local party members and your
constituents and
i suspect an awful lot of people will be
hearing from their constituents about
this in the next couple of days in
addition to those who already
have um but it's also a question of you
know
where i disagree with susie she said
earlier well you know he couldn't be
sacked because dominic cummings wasn't
sacked well
it is possible to learn from past
experience you know if you look at
i got in a lot of trouble with various
people uh online last year when i
wrote at this stage really of the
dominant cummings
round that actually the best thing for
all involved including him would have
been to resign
um at that stage judging from his own
evidence of who he scaled before poland
he in retrospect seems to think that he
ought to have
uh would have been better going some
time around then and i think it is
possible to learn the lessons of things
that have gone wrong
the daily telegraph says you know matt
hancock's job could be at risk if this
becomes a barnard castle well
this already is a barnard castle if you
look if you anybody
watching this opens their family or
neighborhood whatsapp group and looks at
some of the memes that are doing the
rounds you see it's already got cut
through it couldn't be
um you know there's no kind of stay of
process while everyone pauses before
something does electrical damage i'm
i'm sad to say as someone who like likes
matt hancock i'm sad to say that i think
this is already
proving politically damaging and susie
do you think there will be
internal pressure from the conservative
party on boris johnson to
to actually change his mind and and come
forth and
and get rid of matt hancock there's
bound to be because there are a lot of
toy grandees who are
slightly more aware than the prime
minister perhaps of the damage that some
of the
recent scammers have been doing to the
blue base
things that we saw in that the cheshire
and amish by-election when the lib dems
managed to take a tourist seat off them
um and but part of the reason as it's
been as dominic cummings has said and it
appears to be true
that boris johnson hasn't already fired
matt hancock for a
multitude of sins up to this point uh is
because
he's a very good shield you know and if
met hancock were to go
willingly or unwillingly then the
any sort of problems with the pandemic
that continue
in government that can be traced back to
um
this stage or last year that any person
that can get the blame for it then at
some point in the future would be the
prime minister
he would be you know if matt hancock's
not there then whoever the new health
secretary is will be
comparatively clean skin and be able to
say well that was nothing to do with me
governor
and it'll be boris johnson therefore who
gets the blame for things that come out
at some point in the future
um and it's very well having a nice
handy full guy
there ready for you know for you to
defense straight at the right
opportunity but um
you can't keep him forever if he makes
these kind of uh
mistakes mark it doesn't seem um
really difficult to see how he can
survive just looking at the
the i front page with the number of
people that are upset
with with matt hancock we've got berea
family groups uh
saying the pm's failure to sack hancock
is a slap in the face
doctors hit out at breathtaking
hypocrisy
and they're pointing to a poll in which
the majority believe that he should
resign
yes the polling is certainly not looking
good as i made kind of a bleak reference
to earlier and that includes
notably your large proportions of
conservative voters if you wanted to
look at this just
in a partisan sense um i think i mean
it obviously you know by definitely the
definition it is possible that that
they'll
stick it out and simply refuse to change
tag
um you know look what happened last year
as i said earlier with with
the dominant comings kind of barnard
castle incident
the question is firstly whether it's
wise to do that
secondly whether it's right and third if
you
were to decide it was wise and it was
right
um something i would disagree with
obviously um
the question is what would happen next
and you know
learning from experience would involve
recognizing that
what happens next is you suffer the
political damage and eventually
you may well lose the person involved
anyway at which point you've paid
multiples of the price and you haven't
really gotten the upside out of it
yeah it is true to say that your prime
ministers don't like being bounced into
things and forced into things by
definition they're prime ministers they
don't really like having
their own candidates we shall see we
shall see if he'll have his uh hand
force for the minute mark and susie
thank you very much we are going to take
a break
coming up spain breaks ranks with the eu
that help british tourist jet off on a
foreign holiday
[Music]
i'm adam parsons i'm skye's europe
correspondent based here in brussels
nice to see you again mr barney why
meeting you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
police have just made their first move
and they're coming firing
we aim to be the best and most trusted
place for news
there are hundreds of these turbines but
thousands more across gansu
that's what's left of the north tunnel
uh where the north koreans exploded
five nuclear warheads
and this is a show of strength at a time
when china is more fragile than it has
been at any time in recent years
shrapnel from that explosion you can see
it littered along
all the way we take you to the heart of
the stories that shape our world
train station the airport they're both
closed we're not sure about the roads
we've seen reports
that they are being blocked by police so
we're going to try and find a way out
of wuhan after five days
stranded here this is deliverance we
help you
understand the world with us
tom cheshire sky news beijing
this is a forgotten front line they are
dying here
[Music]
boys we've got some interesting ways of
showing you what's going on their
message to us
get ready got the lack of pockets
instructing you to stay at home
i can't believe we did that it's pretty
special isn't it
[Music]
[Music]
we are at a breaking point and we need
to work
now and fast even though young people
are vulnerable
to the importance of climate change
young people can also become the change
agents that we need to address
the climate impact in my campaign or in
advocacy work i work
largely with young people so that their
voices can be heard so they can also
influence
decision making from the local level to
the national level and thankfully
we are making progress in our regard
welcome back you are watching the press
preview still with me
daily mirror economist susie boniface
and chief executive of conservative home
mark
wallace uh susan would come to you first
and let's take a look at the
ft uh momentarily away from matt hancock
and this story
about spain breaking ranks with with
well germany angela merkel wants this
policy of
eu wide quarantining for british
tourists but uh
spain's saying no
at the moment yes so angela merkel the
german chancellor has said
that you know she's concerned about the
delta variant coming into europe by
lots of different nations having
different rules spain has decided
however that it does want to make its
own rules on who can come in and who
can't
and they're desperate to uh restart some
of their tourism industry which sort of
slumped by 80
last year however we do know that
spain's hot spots for new infections are
in the south of the country where lots
of british tourists tend to go far more
than the interior
and they have said that they may
reconsider at some point in the future
there is some pressure to change the
quarantine rule so
while it might be nice to go to majorca
and ibiza right at the moment
go quickly because they might change it
yes yes go quickly come back quickly you
never know when it might change
uh mark we'll just finish off on this um
cartoon this matt cartoon
re matt hancock uh that's not how you
take
a covered swab your thoughts
yes as as ever mata kind of puts his
finger straight on the
um the marmalade dropper of a story that
we saw this morning and i'm afraid
again tomorrow now that we all get the
joys of the actual video clip too